le fabricant de logiciels en
intelligence artificielle coveo de
québec vient de conclure une ronde de
financement de 227 millions de dollars
cette transaction porte sa valeur à 1
milliard 400 millions de dollars
louis têtu et présidente de coveo il est
notre invité ce soir s'étaient tues
bonsoir on se rend mieux finir le 227
les 228 millions de dollars qui sont
injectés proviennent donc du fonds de
retraite des employés municipaux de
l'ontario mres du fonds de solidarité
ftq et d'investissement québec que
signal
en terme de confiance que cet
investissement de ces grands groupes la
ba écoute et je pense que ça signale une
confiance dans l'entreprise et dans son
son succès on a connu une heure une
assez grande croissance depuis les
dernières années on avait levé une ronde
à peu près 100 millions de dollars il ya
18 mois
l'entreprise a dépassé les attentes ce
qui a fait que les investisseurs actuels
sont revenus avec un nouvel investisseur
qui sommes heureuses et on a complété
une ronde lors additionnels ont encore
préservée la grande majorité du capital
qu'on avait levé il ya 18 mois mais
disons que l'entreprise dans un moment
rempli ses coffres des ambitions de
d'investissement de développement c'est
assez importante et à quoi va servir cet
argent cet argent là justement va servir
à développer notre technologie dans le
secteur du commerce électronique noté m
évidemment d'abord pour financer la
croissance parce qu'on a une croissance
très accéléré on embauche ici au québec
à peu près 60 personnes à tous les
trimestres clos dans nos bureaux de
québec et montréal
et puis on est à l'étranger également
mais on va également graissé investir
très agressivement dans le domaine des
solutions d'intelligence artificielle
pour le commerce électronique qui est un
marché qui grossit là une vitesse folle
alors par exemple lorsqu'on va en ligne
google ou facebook va nous proposer
d'acheter un truc ou dali sur des listes
parce que on se rappelle bien qu'on a
visités au cours de notre voyage en
ligne sur le web on a visité toutes
sortes de sites donc vraiment il ya
cette reconnaissance là vous faites ça
pour des entreprises c'est ça en fait le
le vrai challenge et si on regarde les
gens qui nous écoutent probablement ou
une expérience netflix ils ont une
expérience google
ils y connaissent amazon et ainsi de
suite on se rend compte que ces
entreprises là sont excellentes a
utilisé les données pour personnaliser
les interactions et ils prennent dans le
moment des parts de marché là ni vitesse
folle
amazon la proportion du commerce
électronique dans leur américain
d'amazon ont passé de 32% à 42 % dans
les trois dernières années et ça c'est
assez alarmant alors le vrai défi c'est
commun comme un bourreau martineau par
exemple le doit réagir face à sow qui
dans le moment est assez visionnaire là
pour travailler avec les autres avec
coveo notamment comment une entreprise
comme beaucoup martineau pour qu'ils
compétiteurs maintenant ce n'est plus
mariette clairement où le faible le
détaillant de meubles au bar de la rue
son compétiteur il s'appelle loyer faire
les pistes service apple amazon shehu fr
il ya 2200 personnes endettées cnc puis
un développement alors qu'ils utilisent
du dakar puis de l'intelligence
artificielle pour offrir des expériences
clients qui sont très personnalisé à
lorsque kobe au fait c'est de
démocratiser s'appuie de rendre ces
plateformes la de personnalisation par
l'intelligence artificielle qui
utilisent les données qui sont capables
de colliger des données de l'entreprise
puis personnaliser des offres des
recommandations auto autant au niveau du
service que du commerce du web français
disponibles ou à toutes les autres
entreprises si on veut qu'ils doivent
faire face à cette concurrence
des signes on chez david contre goliath
parions sport on peut pas se battre
contre l'intelligence artificielle
utilisé les données de nos jours
utilisez l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un impératif il donne souvent
l'exemple savez
amazon a acheté aux etats-unis la chaîne
au foot par exemple et les gens le
commun des mortels pense que c'est parce
qu amazon voulait vendre de la bouffe
voulait vendre deux voulaient rentrer
dans le bas le commerce de détail les
épiceries et tout ça oui c'est vrai mais
c'est pas le cas si vous achetez du tofu
trois semaines en ligne qu'après ça vous
allez magasiner des livres des souliers
on va tenir contre de tenir compte des
données là dans les yeux de l'amazone
raw food est une entreprise de données
de data
alors comment on utilise le data comment
ils visitent ces gens si cela pour des
entreprises alors nous nous offrons
maîtrise là exactement on offre des
solutions qui permettent à des
entreprises effectivement de livrer ce
genre d'expérience là qui les rendent
compétitive dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
vous avez parlé de brault et martineau
mais j'ai lu que vous avez des clients
aussi comme visa american express sony
dell en fait qu bo et est un leader au
niveau américain gores group la firme
forrester nous reconnaisse comme le
numéro un du marché la personnalisation
numérique
alors oui on a de très très grands
clients des entreprises comme andy
warhol des entreprises vous avez
mentionné mme ameer izzat d'elle
instituée mais comment vous faites pour
arriver à faire concurrence aux géants
du web américain les google de ce monde
par exemple qui dominent tellement de
marché présent il ya deux il ya deux
éléments d'abord on n'est pas à notre
premier rodéo là comme on dit on a bâti
des entreprises de technologie depuis
depuis maintenant l'heure plus de 25 et
on le fait d'abord avec une énorme
confiance dans le talent québécois parce
qu'on n'est pas plus fou que les autres
on a du talent qui est très qualifiés
qui viennent aux universités ainsi de
suite qui est alors qu'on peut mettre à
contribution et on le fait avec des
niveaux d'investissement qui sont
comparés
là ce qu'on va retrouver à palo alto a
cédé kahn vers l'est puis dans d'autres
régions du monde pour concurrencer
disons dans les marchés internationaux
ont investi agressivement en vente
marketing
on a investi dans des produits on
investit dans une bonne compréhension de
ce que les clients veulent et ont fait
de la mise en marché comme n'importe
quelle entreprise se le dise que la
rareté de main-d'oeuvre vous affecte a
baissé sur la rareté de main-d'oeuvre ça
fait longtemps qu'on en parle où il
affecte énormément au québec on a un
manque à gagner de près 30
mais le talent dans le domaine numérique
notamment et donc vous me voyez venir
est ce que la réforme de l'immigration
vous inquiète avait écouté les pros pris
connaissance du détail de la réforme est
ce que je comprends si on parle du grand
thème de l'emploi anticorps anti science
qui regarde mon domaine c'est qu'on a
besoin de plus dix minutes de
d'immigration effectivement parce qu'on
n'a pas suffisamment on a besoin de
davantage d'éducation faut pour offrir
des talents dans le monde numérique
évidemment vous connaissez mon des
balles on a besoin d'arrêter de payer
les entreprises étrangères pour venir à
embaucher des gens ici payent pour
exporter le gain en capital
alors moi je préfère à bâtir des cowboys
au ici qui rendent qui font des
centaines de millions de gains en
capital au fonds de solidarité et je
pense que c'est ça qui va payer le
prochain hôpital la prochaine école
davantage que google amazon et puis et
puis des autres vous en fait la
démonstration en tout cas aujourd'hui
monsieur était dessus merci beaucoup
merci merci monsieur fini